this is some version of hell so today
we're trying to any cooking I didn't
realize quite how tiny everything was I
even never made anything this tiny
before as a tasty producer I am
confident in my cooking abilities today
I'm going to be making a steak and
mashed potato dinner clearly we don't
have a lot of steak today so today I'm
making spaghetti and meatballs normally
if I was making spaghetti and meatballs
I would make the meatballs first but I
think I'm going to test this stove by
just trying to boil water I just want to
see how long that takes so today I'm
making omurice ooh okay so I'm gonna
start with making rice because that
takes the most of the time I'm gonna cut
these up fairly small into a nice fine
dice I'm not gonna bother peeling the
potato because I feel like that would be
an absolute nightmare is this a cooking
utensil or did this come with the stove
is this possibly to make the candle
closer to the top I bet that's what it's
for I don't think it's actually how it
works and we're gonna want this really
really tiny very fine make sure it's
cooked through oh yeah okay so this is
cooked okay now I'm gonna make meatballs
I usually am not very good at making my
meatballs evenly sized but when they're
this small it's like a difference of
being the same size or three times the
size Wow it's bubbling
look at that steam okay so chickens
cooked so I'm going to add onion next
camera
oh you got some steam coming out of the
top look at that or maybe the whole
thing is just on fire and I just like a
light an extra flame next to it is that
an option
we're just speeding things up no I'm
gonna season this with salt and pepper
oh it's making a lot more noise now so
you have to cook with all of your senses
I like doing things with tweezers it's a
lot of fun so far so good
I am very confident it's an usual to be
sitting while cooking you know I give it
a little taste my salt proportion the
way off if you figured out the true
scale of this these would each be like
that thickness have a hot dog I have my
seasoned steak I'm ready to go I'm ready
to sear just want to make sure
everything's in order because this is
gonna be really fast
whoa did you see that time to cook the
meatballs I can tell it's gonna get
pretty hot in there these are like done
in no time I guess that's the that's the
real benefit of tiny cooking oh I'm
getting close to burning actually I
think it's actually overcooked
now what cuz they can do wrong together
yeah it actually smells amazing I'm
happy with this oh okay feel like
everything falls so smooth yeah it's
kind of sticked on the bottom cuz I
wanna make nice folded I go ahead and
season my meatballs a little bit with
some pepper here [ __ ] Wow it's
magnificent here comes the grand finale
when I create a neat pile oh look at
that really looks like spaghetti and
meatballs hey what do you think let's
give this a try seasoned perfectly and
I'm already done so small does it taste
like anything yeah you should eat it
right it's pretty cute I'm not gonna lie
it's a lot of fun I think I think it did
the best I could
I nailed it yeah will I do it again
probably not it's kind of annoying
[Music]